well the age of terminators is getting
closer courtesy of the Pentagon the DoD
plans to spend more than a billion
dollars the next couple of years
developing and deploying military robots
but as technology advances the military
is struggling to keep its current
equipment functioning properly military
plane crashes you may have noticed
already six-year high since October 1st
of last year there have been 12 fatal
accidents that resulted in 35 pilots and
crew dying Colonel David hunters of Fox
News military analyst team joins us
tonight colonel do you see a pattern
here and if so what does it mean yeah
we've been this patterns been coming
since 2013 when sequestration was
approved on top of a 17 year war
constant deployments this was expected
on top of some very bad leadership from
senior military and Pentagon officials
we got planes fall out of the sky and
ships running into each other all over
the world sailors Marines Airmen are
getting killed nobody seems to care
about this a part of this is less than
1% of the nation serves but it's become
bludgeoned by 17 years of war but this
this is very bad business and needs and
this new budget will take about five to
ten years to correct some of this
maintenance issue but the leadership
issue could be fixed right now so when
the ships first started colliding with
one another US naval vessels started
hitting each other hitting other objects
there was a suggestion that maybe their
navigation was being jammed by a foreign
power but you think that's been
discounted and it's really just
incompetence yeah I was absolutely
discounted and then the Navy had to come
play this this is a basic thing you know
I'm an army guy not a Navy guy but
shipping the ocean goes and avoids other
ships on the ocean unless you have an
award and you shoot at them and they've
run into each other and killed sailors
and we relieved a couple of Admirals and
did it one day stand down for safety
this again with 17 years of war and
sequestration which is you know here
earning the budget everybody in uniform
knew that we were going to be short of
money while were fighting
and they've done nothing about this I'm
sorry look it's devastating to me
because we're losing soldiers and
sailors Marines that are not in not in
combat because of incompetence plain and
simple and that could be fixed right now
not all the money in the world will not
fix the bad leadership that led into
this yeah
I can I bet that's exactly right so
given where we are right now and you've
just been explaining the death toll from
it are we ready for a new and expanded
conflict somewhere else in the world
right now no no no we witness again less
than 1% we're still in the middle of
Afghanistan in Iraq and Syria North
Korea from an air standpoint ok but on
the ground battle in North Korea very
very difficult to do with terrain not
mechanized friendly my answer is no 17
years of constant war we've got a great
military but with their tired and the
gear that we're talking about now is
giving out and the next would be the
guys so we we've got to figure this one
out we simply don't seem to want to
would it make very quickly would it make
a difference if we shut down the
Afghanistan operation after all these
years close to two decades and move
those resources somewhere else and gave
the people involved a breather would
that help yeah absolutely it's not just
the guys shooting it's it's five to ten
people behind them that get them to be
healed those are the guys that were
churning out eating up but yeah
Afghanistan wisp it's been going on for
15 years too long anyways that yes that
that's an example of something that
would certainly help the maintenance of
this and the soldiers this is of tired
great force but very very tired of
course they're tired they've got to be
Colonel thank you very much I appreciate
that